the relationship between the u.s and
saudi arabia has been a bit of a roller
coaster this is obviously a challenging
time we've become very good friends they
have to be held accountable as a
presidential candidate joe biden pledged
to punish saudi arabia for its human
rights abuses they're going in and
murdering children and they're murdering
innocent people and he vowed to make
them in fact the pariah that they are
but after major geopolitical shifts in
recent months things might be about to
change the white house formally
announced that biden will visit oil rich
saudi arabia with a meeting between
president biden and saudi crown prince
mohammed bin salman on the horizon what
could the two leaders work toward and at
what cost
here are five key things that are likely
to come up in talks first up oil prices
which have been soaring due to sanctions
on russian oil exports and a supply
demand imbalance created by the pandemic
difficult times for americans across the
u.s as gas prices continue to rise the
average price of gas hit a painful five
dollars a gallon saudi arabia might be
able to help at least to a certain
extent it's one of the world's biggest
oil producers and a leading member of
opec plus a coalition of countries
including russia that controls more than
half of the world's oil exports so far
saudi arabia has largely resisted calls
by the u.s and its european allies to
pump more oil instead sticking to a deal
blessed by russia
but then in june opec plus agreed to up
production by a few thousand barrels a
day it's not a huge amount but it did
draw some praise from the white house
now with a visit biden who is under
pressure to lower prices at the pump
could address the topic in a meeting
since saudi arabia is one of the few
countries in the world capable of
boosting production by a significant
amount
another issue at the top of the list is
security saudi arabia wants greater
military aid and security assurances
from the united states since 2015 the
country has been leading a bombing
campaign in neighboring yemen against
the iran-backed houthi movement the
houthis have been fighting for greater
political sway in yemen and have
retaliated by launching attacks on
targets in saudi arabia
in years past the us provided saudi
arabia with billions of dollars of
military aid
but over the years the saudi-led
campaign has resulted in thousands of
civilian deaths damaged infrastructure
and widespread hunger prompting
president biden to halt the flow of
certain offensive weapons we're not
going to in fact sell more weapons to
them but i would end and the subsidies
that we have and the sale of material to
the saudis recently saudi arabia
extended a truce in yemen a move sought
by the u.s this fragile truce offers the
best hope in years for ending what the
un has called the world's worst
humanitarian crisis
that could pave the way for the u.s to
send more military aid to saudi arabia
u.s and saudi leaders could also work
toward normalizing relations between
saudi arabia and israel officially saudi
arabia doesn't have formal diplomatic
relations with its regional neighbor and
it supports the creation of an
independent palestinian state but in
secret meetings saudi arabia has been
moving toward eventual ties with israel
to further that process the biden
administration has been working to
broker agreements between the two
countries like allowing more commercial
flights from israel to fly over saudi
airspace and transferring ownership of
two red sea islands to saudi arabia a
move that requires israel's blessing
those would be two pretty significant
steps in the direction of normalization
president biden and his team have been
working on this they do see this as a
u.s interest though it might still be
years away normalized relations between
the two countries would reshape politics
in the middle east and it could give
other arab and muslim nations a green
light to recognize israel
next up the leaders may also discuss the
iran nuclear crisis iran has been moving
forward on its nuclear program and
recently it removed cameras monitoring
its work the head of the international
atomic energy agency says this could
deal a quote fatal blow to the iran
nuclear agreement the white house hasn't
yet given up on a revived iran nuclear
deal which was designed to keep tabs on
what iran was producing in order to
prevent it from working on a covert
weapons program but saudi arabia and
some of its neighbors opposed the deal
for fear that it would embolden iran's
leaders finally biden is under pressure
to address the kingdom's human rights
record in a face-to-face meeting with
prince muhammad human rights groups and
saudi dissidents living abroad have
already criticized him for planning to
meet with the very man u.s intelligence
agencies concluded ordered the operation
that killed washington post journalist
jamal khashoggi we will not move on
gemma's legacy will live on
no matter the normal lasik not
normalization efforts the crown prince
has denied having any prior knowledge of
the killing u.s officials across the
political spectrum have also criticized
prince muhammad warning about other
human rights abuses like the jailing of
political opponents the alleged torture
of women's rights activists and mass
executions
many are calling on biden to use his
leverage to demand concrete change
before any meeting takes place i'm not
going to change my view on human rights
but as president united states my job is
to bring peace if i can
clearly the u.s and saudi arabia have a
lot of issues they can work on but many
fear that without demanding action on
human rights issues president biden will
simply enable prince muhammad to
continue ruling with impunity so what do
you think the biden administration
should press for if anything leading up
to the saudi arabia trip leave a comment
below and if you like this video hit the
subscribe button for more stories like
this i'll see you next time
[Music]